Good evening and welcome
to Tucker Carlson Tonight
so if you've been watching
the news you got to give some
credit to whichever MSNBC
contributor wrote the word
so that Joe Biden's speech
earlier if you didn't know
better if you had no context you
might think everything is better
now the great orange emergency
is finally over it's 1996 again
and we can Exhale our Democratic
norms are on their way back out
of Russian cold storage last
month's election was a win
for all of us quote in this
battle for the soul of America
Joe Biden just told us democracy
prevailed.
So it wasn't a partisan exercise
it certainly wasn't theft it was
a victory for you personally
in America Biden speechwriter
wrote politicians don't take
power the people granted
to them.
So Thanks for the civics lesson
Joe Biden Joe Biden wants you
to know he didn't run
for president three times
because he craves power
or because he seeks to enrich is
near to well relatives
or because he has a vast empty
space inside that only
the adulation of strangers can
fill no not at all he ran
for president because he deeply
cares about you Joe Biden is
a paternal figure really you
might even call him the Father
of this nation of course that
would make Kamala Harris
America's permanent stepmother
which doesn't quite have
the same reassuring ring to it.
But whatever details are not
important right now.
What matters Joe Biden wants you
to know is that this is
a democracy always has been,
always will be and by electing
Biden and the small secretive
group of billionaires who
choreograph his every move this
country has become even more
Democratic small C Democratic
of course and that's reassuring
to hear honestly because some
of us were starting to get other
impressions non-democratic ones
just the other day,
for example Bill Gates announced
that
the lockdown's we're enduring
are going to have to continue
for a long long time now keep
in mind Bill Gates is not
an epidemiologist he's not
a research scientist either Bill
Gates is a retired 65-year-old
from Seattle who used to make
mediocre software for office
computers but now
he's a billionaire therefore
Bill Gates gets to decide
our national health policy
pretty much the same way retired
hedge fund operator Tom Steyer
gets to tell you what to think
about the weather or how
78-year-old Mike Bloomberg
decides which guns you can buy
or how George Soros can choose
your prosecutors or how Tim Cook
of Apple runs our trade policy
or
how Zuckerberg of Facebook can
keep America's borders open just
because he feels like it
but nobody says anything
because his friend fellow
billionaire Jeff Bezos owns
Washington d.c. hometown
newspaper and may soon by CNN
that is the democracy Joe Biden
is talking about the kind
of democracy in which 11 wing
billionaires who fund his
campaigns run everything
that's the Chinese model
of democracy that Joe Biden
and his friends so admire so get
used to it America it's a new
kind of democracy in China
people in power don't have
to answer questions.
So neither does Joe Biden just
last year a voter brought up
the Biden family's corruption
during a town hall event and Joe
Biden responded by calling
the man fat and challenging him
to a push up contest just like
the Chinese do just this Friday
an op Ed in the Wall Street
Journal pointed out that Joe
Biden's wife Dr. Jill Biden
isn't actually a real doctor
sorry she's not going to be
treating for high blood pressure
Dr. Jill Biden has the very same
degree as Dr. Bill Cosby does
which is one degree from Dr.
pepper but Joe Biden and his
friends didn't want to hear that
we'll tell you how they've how
they've responded in just
a moment.
But before we do, we have some
actual journalism to report
tonight on Friday a reporter
with this network Peter Doocy
tried to get Joe Biden
to address a factual issue his
son Hunter Biden is now under
federal criminal investigation
relating to tax fraud stemming
from his business deals
in China.
So here's how the conversation
went after buying information
from have you spoken
to you're trying to break away
from my I am proud of my son
said Joe Biden if that sounds
familiar there's a reason
that's the same rehearsed non
sequitur that the Biden Harris
transition team sent out
in a press release last week
and you're not getting any more
information than that just
a minute ago, we heard about how
in America politicians
don't take power the people
granted to them but it turns out
the people granting that power
don't get answers what we do
know is that Joe Biden is very
proud of his son and his
son's federal criminal
investigation.
And that's all you need to know
so why isn't Joe Biden willing
to answer even basic questions
about his son's foreign business
dealings the ones where he had
lucrative arrangements very
lucrative arrangements with
companies directly tied
to the Communist Party of China
well possibly it's because Joe
Biden himself was directly
involved in those deals and has
been lying about them.
We've been telling you that
for more than a month and now
it's obvious one
of Biden's former business
partners Tony belinski already
presented contemporaneous
documentation proving that
the reason the press Corps
and their allies in Silicon
Valley did everything they could
to bury that story is that they
knew perfectly well that more
evidence was coming
and it's arrived that's evidence
that they can't suppress this
week in the Daily Caller
obtained new evidence emails
from Hunter Biden here's 1
September,
2017 Hunter Biden wrote to his
building manager in Georgetown
in Washington d.c. and he wrote
this quote please have keys made
available for new officemates
colen Joe Biden Jill Biden Jim
Biden the brother gangling donc
chairman of qfes f.c.
emissary Oh so the new
officemates included the former
vice president his doctor wife
and gangling dong representing
CFC the Chinese energy company
that according to emails
published by the New York Post
was reserving a 10% equity stake
for Joe Biden the man that goong
wendong represented
cfc's chairman he has ties
to the Chinese military
and intelligence services
apparently he's since
disappeared somewhere
in mainland China but according
to an August 20 '17 email
written by Hunter Biden chairman
he also offered Biden a three
year $30 million contract
for quote introductions alone
to whom you know who his dad Joe
Biden as we said Germany has
since disappeared apparently
he's been arrested by Chinese
authorities if all
this seems a little dodgy to you
not quite a straightforward
business deal you should know
that back in 2019 Joe Biden
wasn't repeating the same line
about being proud of his son no
he went on the record and denied
he knew anything about his
son's business relationships
abroad,
including with Chinese
communists the very same
relationships that were slated
to make him rich I never
discussed with my son
or my brother or anyone else
in me having to do with
their business period I've never
discussed it said Joe Biden it
never came up even in the office
with gong Wang dong and Dr. Jill
Biden we talked about sports
and how proud Joe Biden was
of his son,
the one under federal criminal
investigation the truth is Joe
Biden must think people are
as slow as he's become this
isn't even a solid cover
the point of the Biden political
operation one of them anyway
from the very beginning has been
to make as much money influence
peddling as possible.
So if you're wondering how Joe
Biden who's been in public
office since 1972 that's just
the federal level almost 50
years how has Joe Biden been
able to live in 10,000 square
foot homes almost the entire
time a number of them.
How do you do that
on a government salary how did
Hunter Biden go from
unemployable to rich virtually
overnight well you know
the answer they haven't even
tried to hide it back in January
20 '17 a man called Eric sherwen
he was then the president
of Biden's company which is
called rosemonde Seneca road
to Hunter Biden to warn him that
things are getting a little too
obvious here's a quote from
the email in 2014 you joined
the tourism board in Ukraine.
And we still need to amend
your 2014 tax returns to reflect
the unreported income that is
approximately $400,000 extra
to your income in 2014 was
closer to one million $247,328
and quote now we don't know,
because we're not the IRS with
Hunter Biden ever amended his
tax returns to account
for the hundreds of thousands
of dollars he was making from
Ukrainian oligarchs
in a business that his father
made possible by firing
the prosecutor who was going
to hurt the company that was
paying hundreds Biden we're not
making any of this up we're not
into conspiracy theories
that's all true and it unfolded
in public the DOJ investigation
presumably is looking into all
of that.
But the emails from Eric sherwen
do offer another window
into the kind of life the Bidens
were living here's his email
to Hunter Biden since you
couldn't have lived
on approximately $550,000 a year
sherwen wrote to Hunter Biden
you quote borrowed some money
from Rosemont Seneca in advance
of those payments Syria
of Hunter Biden the Son of Joe
Biden, who is himself a son
of Scranton,
Pennsylvania son of a coal miner
took Amtrak to work every day
this is a person who became
so dependent on peddling
influence that he couldn't live
on a $550,000 a year salary this
is the person Joe and Dr. Jill
Biden are proud of the rest
of us and this is not a personal
attack it's just true
if you're going to restore
democracy the rest of us have
a right to know exactly where
the money came from what did
they do for it and what effect
is it going to have
on the country going forward
in a democracy that's a very
basic request
and there's nothing Democratic
about ignoring the question
in fact,
it just confirms what's obvious
which is they don't plan
to govern this as a democracy
but instead as an oligarchy.